jérôme rodriguez sera fixé le 6 avril au
cur heures lui demande la relaxe figure
du mouvement des gilet jaune
il comparaissait devant le tribunal
correctionnel de paris aujourd'hui lui
reprochait d'avoir injurié des policiers
sur twitter en septembre dernier dans un
échange de messages avec le syndicat de
police synergie
il avait alors fait une analogie entre
les forces de l'ordre et le régime nazi
évoquant également un camp de
concentration dans le nord-est de paris
mais de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
avait qualifié ces propos d' ignoble
annonçant qu'une plainte allait être
déposée écoutez la réaction
le jérôme rodriguez à l'issue de sa
comparution devant le tribunal
correctionnel
ça ça mieux que moi ce que j'ai dit que
j'ai insulté la police
non non les gars allez écrire des films
seraient beaucoup meilleure affaire ça
que de prétendre ce que moi j'ai dit
j'ai dit bond de l'asie et ça s'adresse
aux syndicats tout simplement au
bénéfice du doute
en tous les cas il à hilla au jeu même
pas certain qu'ils aient le goût je
pense qu'il est c'est confirmé je ne
m'adresse pas tout la police donc il a
demandé la relaxe et continue
aujourd'hui à faire passer rodriguez
pour 1 et le dkfz mehdi un une-deux des
keufs
alors c'est pas vrai on continue à faire
passer rodriguez pour le plus violent
des violents alors que c'est parlerait
c'est tout j'ai pas de casier je suis
pas violent moi je suis là pour militer
pour les droits sociales et fiscales je
la prenais mieux vivre de l'ensemble de
mes camarades je suis là pour faire en
sorte d'avoir une des vocations et
directe et participative et de mettre
fin à toutes les saloperies contraint de
mettre en place aujourd'hui le
gouvernement
l'accord aujourd'hui les responsables
c'est pas les keufs d'accord les
responsables c'est le gouvernement qui
utilise des flics pour mettre en place
un bouclier pour les protéger de leur
connerie c'est la seule chose